my husband and I are not on the same
page with money and I don't have control
over the money unless he gives it to me
we have one debt left and we could pay
it off in one to two months if we work
together but there's just no urgency
from him my sanity is on the brink and
I'm tired of arguing with my husband and
being run over by my in-laws I've talked
to my husband and tried to lay
boundaries but then I'm just a control
freak according to my mother-in-law is
getting away from my mother-in-law going
to fix things or am I the issue based on
exactly what you wrote and I always want
to hold in both hands there's there's
there's two sides to a story you are not
the issue yes getting away from your
mother-in-law would fix some things but
the bigger thing here is you have a
husband who is over over overbearing
does not have a partner um he is much
more interested in making sure his
mommy's okay and um his mommy's brought
into all of your life than he is being
married and building a life with you
co-creating a world with his wife